the texans got permission yesterday to
interview eric b enemy the league which
never changes rules which is like very
resistant to any type of change they've
been changing rules left and right this
year and they changed the rule that said
to the texans hey you didn't interview
the guy during the bye week you can't
talk to him until after the chief season
ends
the league agreed to let it happen the
chiefs agreed to let it happen they
interviewed eric b enemy and others
yesterday matt eberflus who initially
declined the colts defensive coordinator
sat for the interview
leslie frazier the bill's defensive
coordinator as well so the texans are
are commencing a more earnest and
thorough search now that they have a gm
i thought it was stupid to interview
coaches before you hire your gm right
and uh and now you've got your gm and
now and now they can see what they want
to do if i'm eric behind me though i'm
very leery if i'm any of these guys i'm
leery because i want to know what
deshaun watson
thinks what he wants and before i would
ever accept that job i want two hours
with the show up to two hours with
deshaun watson i don't need that i know
that i need two maybe i only need five
minutes but i want to know that this
guy's on board with me before i get on
board with the texans well i mean at
least eric the enemy knows to a degree
he at least knows that like hey deshaun
watson's my you know a fan of mine
uh but you know again this this whole
situation
is so weird
uh the fact that it's you know that
they're asking eric b enemy at this
point finally
i don't know could could the eric b
enemy hire
be one that puts the toothpaste back in
the tube with the houston texans and
deshaun watson maybe i don't know the
way i feel right now and the rumors you
hear around the nfl and everything like
that i just feel like
i mean that might be the only thing that
saves deshaun watson with the houston
texans i feel like it's
he's out of there unless it's just maybe
they blow them away here with something
and as far as the coaching higher i just
thought it doesn't seem like it's
heading in the right direction from
everything we know we've heard so far
you know you and i know people through
the back channels and we've we've talked
about it a little bit uh so this is this
is a very weird situation and i think
the whole situation around eric b enemy
is weird too the fact that he's been
this good this successful yeah he's a
raw interview because he's a head coach
he's a real football coach and you know
he's not
you know what do i want to say
persuading or you know
using
any of these owners to to win them over
in these interviews i think that's a
curious conversation too
we talked about last week bruce aaron's
wasn't a good interview mike zimmer
wasn't a good interview those guys don't
they're two they're two in your face
they're two like
they tell you the truth and then some of
these want their butts kissed right yeah
i mean well
i wouldn't say some i would say most if
not all and it's not that they want it
that they're used to that that's the
bubble you live in that's part of the
billionaire privilege you're surrounded
by sycophants that's what makes that
scene from when george costanza gets
hired by the yankees so damn compelling
because he tells off george steinbrenner
nobody tells off george steinbrenner
nobody tells off jeffrey laurie nobody
tells off cal mcnair they they figure
out how to properly keep their lips
affixed to their rear ends that's how
you remain employed so when somebody
comes in and starts telling you why your
team sucks and why you're not doing a
good job of running your team well
you're off the list buddy because you're
not speaking the language and the
language is oh hello sir how are you
today is there anything i can get you
today boy your suit looks great today oh
wow you know oh your hair is impeccable
i mean and it's not quite that fawning
but that's kind of the reality that's
kind of how it goes that's kind of
what's so compelling about the national
football league to me all these teams
owned by essentially monarchies who who
know nothing at their core for the most
part about football
and then they have to make football
decisions but as to the enemy in the
texans my hesitation if i'm the enemy is
i want to know
that me taking the job fixes it with
watson i don't want to find out that
watson's going to look at this and say
now they had their chance and this is
just an effort to try to placate me
nothing has really changed they've just
they've just added another person to the
mix
to kind of cover up the fact that they
really don't care about me they don't
care about making it any better this is
just a way to try to keep me from asking
for a trade it's too little it's too
late if i'm the enemy i want to know
oh whether or not that's his reaction
before i take that yeah i think you have
to know at this point almost you have to
the the league the league has been set
on fire by this desean watson
conversation
that's just what i know i think there's
a lot of teams doing homework right now
going what do we have to trade to get to
sean watson any team that's got a
quarterback question they're thinking
about it right now there's too many of
them out there i know that i've heard
from other people who know this is a
huge story and everybody's keeping their
eye on it right now this is this is
gonna be something to watch and yeah i
wonder if the enemy can salvage the
situation or not or deshawn's done with
it but um we don't get in this situation
too often with a big time superstar
quarterback like this
somebody asked me yesterday who's
interested in desean watson i said i
think it would be easier to pull out
who's not teams right and scratch off
the ones who shouldn't be exactly
because that that's that's an easier
conversation that's right um and uh yeah
the next move the texans make will go a
long way possibly maybe it's too late
but he's yet to say the magic words
trade me because he knows once he does
he can't go back so there's still a
shred but they're gonna have to do a lot
i think at this point to convince him
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports